hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
today we're talking about how to
exponentiate
efficiently spoiler alert this video was
inspired by project euler's problem
number 122.
suppose for a moment that we don't have
access to the built-in exponentiation
operator or any math library that's
going to do it for us
put yourself in the position of someone
who might be trying to write one of
those libraries
this is the kind of thing that you might
have to think about if you were writing
a programming language or a compiler for
a programming language
here i have the most obvious way you
could possibly implement raising
something to the 15th power
namely just start with the variable and
multiply it by itself
14 more times assuming i didn't make a
typo
if you count the number of stars you'll
see that this requires 14
multiplications
but you can actually compute x to the
15th power using far fewer
the first clever thing that you might
think to do is to use the binary
expansion of the number 15.
as we can see from the binary
representation 15 requires 4 powers of 2
1 2 4 and 8. we can compute those by
repeatedly squaring
i compute x squared is x times x then x
to the fourth is x squared times x
squared
then x to the eighth is x to the fourth
times x to the fourth
then to get x to the 15th power i just
read off the binary expansion
i need an x to the eighth i need an x to
the fourth i need an x squared and i
need an
x this allows me to compute x to the
15th power and only
six multiplications additionally 15
isn't really special here i could have
done the same thing using basically any
positive
integer first write it in binary compute
all the powers of 2 that i need by
repeatedly squaring
and then put those powers of 2 together
according to the number's binary
expansion to get the number
the number of multiplications needed for
this method scales approximately
logarithmically with the size of this
number 15
this is much better than the linear
number of multiplications
that we used in the naive method okay so
what's the minimum number of
multiplications that i could possibly
get away
with well for 15 here's the answer
you compute x squared and then x cubed
and then x to the sixth then 12th
then the 15th however
unlike the binary example there's no
clear pattern as to how i got these
numbers
well it turns out this is a very hard
problem
the best algorithms so far are
essentially try
every possible sequence of numbers and
see which ones give you the least
multiplications
there are certainly some tricks that
have been found that allow you to rule
out some bad guesses and things like
that
but in general this is still an
exponential time problem
no one really knows how to do any better
you might think this is silly when does
anyone raise something to the 15th power
but people really do care about this
even in real life
look what happens when i put this
example into compiler explorer
on the left i write x times x times x 15
times
on the right you can see both for gcc
and clang
that each of these assembly outputs only
uses six multiplications
this isn't a coincidence the people who
wrote those compilers
cared about this problem before we dive
into the code to try to find these
numbers
first let's note that we can represent
this whole computation process
just with a string of numbers the
numbers are just the powers and the
order that i compute them in
so for the minimal example i compute x
to the one then x squared then cubed
then to the sixth then twelfth then
fifteenth
as you might guess i'm going to be
storing these numbers in a tuple
we will then successively try all the
possibilities
what can we make in one multiplication
in two multiplications in three
multiplications and so on
because in the process of computing the
most efficient way to exponentiate for
some power
i'll also compute a whole bunch of other
powers i'm going to represent
and store all the information that i
compute during the algorithm
i will store all that information inside
a class which i can then ask to compute
more and more and more
until it finds the numbers that i'm
looking for
i'll start with an initial chain of just
1 meaning
x to the first power i don't need to do
any computations to get x to the first
power
this map will keep track of for each
number what is a
minimal length chain that ends up at
that number
so when i plug in 15 i should get this
chain or
at least one that's the same length
every time i multiply n plus one things
together
i first multiply n things together so i
know that when i compute the next step
of the algorithm
i'm going to use the answers from the
previous step for that reason i'll use
this variable
cached chains to store the answers from
the previous step
the step variable tells me what step of
the algorithm i'm in how many
multiplications am i using
and the step limit just tells me not to
go too far so i don't run out of memory
computing a single step is definitely
the hard part of the algorithm
first i check that i haven't stepped too
far and then i increase the step count
i iterate through all the chains of one
less length and for each of them i need
to compute what are all the new chains
of one more length that i can make from
them
this corresponds to multiplying two
smaller powers that we've already
computed
for instance for this chain i could add
on an 18 by using 6 and 12
or a 21 by using 6 and 15. you might
think that for a given chain in order to
extend it i need to try all possible
pairs of elements in the chain
but it turns out that for exponents
smaller than this
it's always okay to assume that one of
the numbers is the largest number in the
list
it is by no means obvious that assuming
this will still give you the right
answer
i'm not going to even try to explain why
this is allowed
but i will link to a good starting point
a research paper that you can read if
you want to look into it
okay so i will always assume that one of
the two powers that i'm using is the
biggest one that is the last thing in
the list
for the other one i just try all the
other things in the list
then i compute the exponent that i get
by using those two smaller exponents
i make a new chain that has now one more
thing on the end of it and then i add
that
to my set of newly computed chains now
the important part
if this is the first time i have ever
seen this exponent
then i set this chain as the minimal
chain for that exponent
i use the built-in dictionary method set
default to do this
what set default does is if a key
already exists in a dictionary it does
nothing
but if it doesn't exist in the
dictionary then it sets the value
this ensures that each number is linked
to the first chain
that produces that number subsequent or
longer chains
will not overwrite this value the last
thing that we need to do
is set all the chains that we just
computed to be the new cache for the
next step
then we make a little helper function
which will facilitate finding the answer
for a specific
exponent basically we just keep
computing
longer and longer chains until the set
default finally finds a chain that is
able to produce the desired number
then to find a chain for a specific
exponent we just
step until it's computed and then return
it
if for some reason we only cared about
the number of multiplications and not
the actual chain that tells us how to
get there
then we can just note that the number of
multiplications is
one less than the length of the chain so
here's how you would put it together to
solve the project euler question
which asks us to compute the sum of the
first 300
answers i'll time my answer to make sure
it doesn't take more than one minute
i set the end that i'm looking for as
the number 300
then i create an instance of my class
just for my benefit i want to print out
all the chains
and then for project euler i'll just go
ahead and sum up the answers
let's see how it goes okay it looks like
we finished with an answer of 2593
in 51 seconds scrolling up towards the
top here we do see
that it found the same answer that i
mentioned before for 15
1 2 3 6 12 15. also notice that it's not
a monotonic function
sometimes a bigger exponent can take
less multiplications
the last thing that i want to mention is
that although we did this problem
for multiplication of just integers we
can actually say the exact same thing of
multiplication of any kind of objects
as long as i know what it means to
multiply a thing by itself i can make
sense of exponentiating something or
raising it to an integer power
this allows the answer to be useful in a
more general context
beyond just what you would get for
integers for integers after all
when's the last time you ever raised
something to a power other than two
three or maybe four imagine for a moment
that x
is not an integer but a one million by
one million matrix
saving even just one multiplication
might be meaningful when you have a
problem this large
i also want to point out that there are
many matrix models that are useful in
applications
you start out with a vector and then
repeatedly multiply by a matrix to get
the next state in the model
that means if you want to know what
happens a thousand time steps later in
the future
that's equivalent to multiplying by the
matrix to the power one thousand
this is another place where taking a big
power of an object comes up
well that's all i've got on this topic
if you enjoyed the video please consider
subscribing and telling your friends
and as always don't forget to slap that
like button an odd number of times